yo what is up everybody Mather we need
you here with another Dark Souls 3 video
now in this video I'm gonna be giving
you guys my thoughts and ideas about
Aldrich that I couldn't put into the
normal video because it was just didn't
really fit anywhere so if you're looking
for high quality lower content this
isn't really the place but if you have a
few lingering questions from my Aldrich
lore video then this is the place quick
note this is gonna be a pretty low
quality video in terms of production
value because I'm just rushing to get
this out I was pretty busy today and I
and I just want to get this video out
for you guys today so you guys can hear
my thoughts on the subject
so if you haven't seen my all dirge
video lore video you're gonna probably
think this is a little bit weird so go
check that out and if you have seen that
here we go alright so the first Theory
Aldrich is small smoke smog smokes make
the guy who ate people in Dark Souls 1 I
don't really see enough evidence for
this for this case other than they are
both man-eaters smoke was cannon AMA CLE
killed in Dark Souls 1 and you could say
that it could have been an illusion
because Ornstein was confirmed as an
illusion and that's who he fought with I
don't totally believe it especially
smokes armor in Dark Souls 3 states that
he was the last night to stand in
defense of the ruined cathedral so I'm
assuming that when when we fought him
that was really him I think that's where
he died that's it alright number two
Aldridge is the chosen undead the only
thing I can see holding this together is
that they both consumed which is a
little bit flimsy in my mind also the
endings of Dark Souls 3 kind of imply
that the dark ending in Dark Souls 1
could also be canon to due to the
cyclical nature of fire and dark so the
chosen undead from Dark Souls 1 might
not have had to link the flame cannon on
eclis which would mean that he wouldn't
be Aldridge because we know Aldridge did
link the flames into the Lord cinder
that would be the end of this theory and
I think that that just kind of disproves
all right next up is Aldridge 8 nito
slash the witch of izalith I hear a lot
that alder Jade nido and I don't think
alder Tate nito first talking about the
witch of izalith the fire in Aldridge's
second phase is what people talk about
in terms of the connection to the witch
but this is a theme that is shared
between all of the lords of cinder they
all have it during the second phase of
they all have a second phase of fire so
I don't really see that as support then
for nito that I guess you can say there
are some similarities his
weapon is somewhat similar however we
have seen him copy weapons just from
dreaming about them such as Priscilla's
life hunt scythe and the bones and men
all around I don't see that as enough
just because he consumed men so it makes
sense that the men are there also nito's
soul was can anomaly consumed in Dark
Souls 1 in the Lord vessel so you can
say it like broke apart and went
somewhere
but even so that means that he only
absorbed the soul so he didn't actually
eat neither since we know Neto was dead
and from before what I said
I don't think altars is the chosen
undead so that means that Aldridge
wasn't around when Neto died so that
would stop this from being a possibility
all right next up we got the deep and
the abyss their connections alright so
the deep could be the abyss or some form
of the abyss or the abyss in some way
however it's kind of just up in the air
right now I've heard theories about the
deep being the true abyss like the one
from the four knights fight back in Dark
Souls 1 which means there's like no dirt
or anything else there's just only black
like in the fight we have with highlord
wall near there's some stuff and grounds
that's not true abyss and so that could
be plausible I don't know enough about
the deep even from doing the elders
video to say whether it is or isn't so I
didn't bring it up in the video because
I think it would just get confusing I
only said what I was fairly confident in
the video and III don't know if the D
board is the abyss or it isn't alright
and so now we have a your snow who is
the tower made in near aldrich and it
would make somewhat sense to talk about
her in the alders video because she was
near and she was connected to pontiff
and she did give some information on
Gwendolyn however I there's a lot of
stuff she could be implicated in so I'm
gonna wait till I know a lot more about
her before I discuss her because of all
our connections with pontiff and aldrich
and the previous royal family like the
family of wind the line of wind I don't
know I don't know much about her yet so
I'm gonna wait to talk about it and then
lastly we have positive Sullivan um I'm
probably gonna do a lore video on him
next like that's my next target I think
not nothing's confirmed but I really
enjoy all the connections of the story
behind pontiff and there's a lot of
stuff to talk about so you really
interests me so I might do him I might
do another Lord of cinder like you're
more the abyss waters but I don't know
so yeah pontiff Sullivan I'm probably do
new lore videos that will cover all the
about him all right thank you guys for
watching this just my short little blurb
spiel whatever and yeah I hope you guys
they have a good day thank you for
watching peace out